hin zur entzündung zur kunst an und für
sich nun hundert jahre später zeigen das
zentrum paul klee und das kunstmuseum
bern die doppelausstellung die
revolution ist tot lang lebe die
revolution hier also nullpunkt der
abstraktion
doch die revolution schmaler mit ihrer
propaganda kunst zur gestaltung einer
neuen gesellschaft im zentrum
sozialistischer malerei steht die
arbeitswelt wo die menschen im kollektiv
an der neuen zukunft bauen
das individuum interessiert nur als
vorbild dem alle nacheifern sollen in
der sowjetunion vorwärts epe wo das
heißt sowie die us autostadt und zwar
strategisch mit plakat mit der konsum
zur sprache
sda die sozialistische versprachen die
frauen seien in den technischen
fortschritt vorantreiben um den
sozialismus und kapitalismus das
ablehnen und seine 20 zeit wer wen wer
wird mal der wettbewerb grüner
kapitalismus oder sozialismus und das
hat auch künstler beflügelt richtig
stimmung gemacht wurde dass der
wettbewerb
kunst im dienst ideologische ziele
erfüllt sie diese anforderung nicht wie
der formalismus eines leavitt ist die
sinnlos konterrevolution er malerei soll
anschaulich seien realistisch und eben
sozialistisch auf anordnung des
darlehens wird alles kunstschaffen 1934
zentral organisiert und für alle geht
der sozialistische realismus als
zielvorgabe sowjetunion hat ihre helden
pocht
sie hat die hilfe gefunden mit
arbeitswelt aber überarbeitet eric und
je höher sie ist desto besser der stahl
ihm aber er hat es bei der partei kubas
war stalin und linien wir ihnen einfach
schuldig wie alexander gerassimez er in
selber funktion eher status und
künstlerische verehrung
wer nicht pariert es geht darum kritik
ist liebs gefährlich begrüßt die
einfache frühestens übrigen durchaus
texanischen roscoe sich wanderer und
acht worden sind hatte petrow watkin die
fröhliche szene male von honig die welt
und die ganze gefahr von denunziert
werden wir diese bilder zeigt die beiden
hier intermezzi von den kindern eine
fröhliche lügner als bürgerlich wohnen
tisch zeigt und schmutzigem geschirr
schmutzige wäsche
da wird klar wird die danach sind dann
plötzlich dass einige von seinen figuren
ganz hinterlistiger blickfeld auch
direkt aus dem bilderbuch zu sorgen oder
einen da wird die nation zeit zum malen
im zweiten weltkrieg erleiden die
verkehrs schwere demütigungen und
riesige verluste nach dem weg will
stalin umso energischer neuen optimismus
und erfolgserlebnisse sehen ereignis im
sowjetische alter wohnort hat sich zum
späteres mietwohnungen kraftwerk und es
ist auch wichtige typisch beispiel für
schönfärberei sozialistischen realismus
der bilder ist immer so ins wasser
manche sind immer fröhlich gesund
attraktiv gekleidet
nach stalins tod 1953 beginnt unter
chruschtschow eine periode des
politischen tauwetters die malerei
bleibt offiziell dem sozialistischen
realismus verpflichtet doch im
untergrund machen sich widerspenstige
künstler an die demontage dieser
bildsprache
in dem bild körperstrafen großes lemming
packard und der umstand dass man achtlos
auf oder dem plakat und andy roddick
setzte wichtige linie vorgibt das ist
richtig
das entlaufene spiel mit der
ideologischen symbolik wird so zart
genannt parallel zur westlichen pop art
die den konsum waren bloßstellt
besonders aktiv sind russische maler im
new yorker exil revolution als gekrönte
totgeburt im horror museum der
geschichte nach dem ende der sowjetunion
wird der sozialistische realismus auch
in russland selber karikiert die fabrik
helden von einst sie schlachten jetzt
die dämonen der vergangenheit und heute
die klassische bildung sozialistische
realismus aus der stalin sieht wie wir
entdeckt in russland die große
ausstellung mit und sie werden benutzt
um und ist kapital schlagen der ganze
kult um das stalin legitimierter damit
auch jetzt die jüngsten ist nachdem
starker mann russlands
[Musik]